so mental health disorders affects up to
one in five adults in the United States
and contribute substantially to the
worldwide morbidity and mortality the
lives of individuals with mental
disorders are cut short by 10 years on
average and this is why Walker 2015. so
hi I'm schlot FASA a third year PhD
student in computational neuroscience
and today I want to talk about
computational Psychiatry because
currently I'm working on some projects
in computational Psychiatry and I want
to introduce this topic to you such that
you may work in it yourself research it
a bit more yourself and I want to give
you the tools tips techniques and tricks
to learn more about this field so first
of all what is computational Psychiatry
so computational Psychiatry is an
interdisciplinary field that uses
computational methods and models to
understand the underlying mechanisms of
mental disorders and to develop new
treatments for these disorders this
field combines the techniques from
computer science mathematics and
engineering with the knowledge from
neuroscience and Psychiatry to create
mathematical models of the brain and
behavior these models can be used to
simulate brain activity test hypotheses
about the causes of mental disorders and
predict the effect of different
treatments the goal of computational
Psychiatry is to gain a deeper Insight
in the understanding of the biological
physiological and environmental factors
that contribute to mental disorders and
to use this understanding to develop
more effective and personalized
treatments so a big difference between
computational neuroscience and
computational Psychiatry is then the
emphasis on the patients and the
clinicians so instead of just wanting to
create computational models that pertain
to the mean of the distribution we
really want to understand the effects
for people that are lying more on the
edges of the distribution so what you
can imagine is just like when you have
cancer for example and you go to the
doctor and your oncologist might monitor
tumor markers to dynamically optimize
chemotherapy psychiatrists might monitor
your brain conductivity changes to
rapidly optimize an antidepressant
regime for example if you're struggling
with antidepressants and currently this
type of personalized medicine that's
really specified for the individual is
not yet available but this is really a
goal that computational Psychiatry wants
to achieve because we have such Rich
knowledge in neuroscience and also data
from neuroimaging that could potentially
help several people that are struggling
with their mental health so I want to
tell you a little bit about where we are
now where we're going and how you could
contribute if you're interested in this
field so chapter one is about where we
currently are so at the moment the DSM-5
is one of the most well-known manuals to
diagnose several patients with their
mental disorders so the DSM-5 is the
diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders however ever since the
DSM-5 has been introduced to the field
or ever since the DSM has been
introduced to the field there have been
a lot of controversies surrounding the
DSM so for example strikingly according
to the DSM definition it is possible for
two people to receive the same diagnosis
of a major depressive disorder without
sharing a single symptom one MDD patient
may experience a depressed mood weight
gain constant tiredness and fatigue and
regularly think about ending their lives
whereas another MDD patient may
experience anedonia loss of weight and
go through psychomotor and concentration
difficulties so you can see that the
same diagnosis can be given to several
patients without them having any of the
same symptoms and the same thing is with
the causes so people can have the same
causes we think biologically without
receiving the same diagnosis from their
psychiatrist and this has led to quite a
controversy what exactly these diagnosis
mean why there is such a difference
between several psychiatrists when they
diagnose the same patient is there any
like underlying value and these kind of
problems have been present in the field
of Psychiatry since the beginning and
for example one quote that I really
think shows this problem quite nicely is
from John Ronson the psychopath tests a
journey through the madness industry so
he says about the DSM I bought the book
and lived through it I closed the manual
I wonder if I've got any of the 374
mental disorders I thought I opened the
manual again and instantly diagnosed
myself at at least 12 different ones and
this is also something that's quite
common that people that in general feel
they don't have necessarily a mental
disorder or they're not struggling in
life necessarily but they could be
according to the DSM-5 diagnosed with
several mental disorders so and in
general psychiatrist interests of course
are aware of these problems this is not
something new that I'm introducing here
for the first time but the fact is that
the DSM-5 is usually quite a useful tool
to start understanding a patient and
explain to them what they are perhaps
could be struggling with but one of the
goals of computational Psychiatry is
that they want to have a more
fundamental in a sense of a biological
explanation that kind of converges to
more clear distinct categories so that
brings us to chapter 2 where we are
going so in general the goals of
computational Psychiatry so one of the
main goals of computational Psychiatry
is to find biological so grounded in
Neuroscience or genetic relevant labels
or to find labels that could prove to be
clinically useful such that we can know
for which patient for example which type
of medicine would work better based on
their genetics environment or brain
signature and to reach this type of goal
we really want to bring the knowledge
from computational neuroscience back
into the clinic and one major shift that
has to be made within the field of
computational Neuroscience to allow for
this knowledge to go towards
computational Psychiatry is that it
needs to be individualized because a lot
of computational Neuroscience trials and
also research has been done between two
populations so usually we compare a
population of relatively healthy
individuals and a population of
individuals that might be struggling and
then we look at the means of these two
populations and see if these differ but
you can imagine that Within These
population there is a large amount of
variability and heterogeneity so for
example a healthy individual in
population number a could still be
struggling with certain symptoms of
depression whereas for example a patient
that is diagnosed with depression but
relatively well functioning could be
actually quite similar to the healthy
population the fact is that within
patients that have been diagnosed with
mental disorders there is a high
heterogeneous 80 but also within the
healthy population so we don't really
want to compare these two populations
with each other we would actually want
to understand for each individual person
how their mental health looks like
biologically genetically and also how it
is expressed in their environment so
that brings us to chapter three what
kind of models are being currently used
in computational Psychiatry and how can
you learn more about them so I really
want to give you here like the resources
the tools tell you a little bit about
the data that you could find or use such
that if you're interested in this field
you could kind of start learning about
it more from scratch using these
materials so as I said for computational
Psychiatry almost the same type of
models are being used as in
computational Neuroscience but they're
really being specified for individual
participants and we also want to know a
little bit more usually about the causal
mechanisms that cause these mental
disorders so three types of models are
commonly used and that's reinforcement
models Bayesian models and also new
neural networks nowadays are quite
popular so in reinforcement learning
models so reinforcement learning is a
research field that lays at the
intersection between mathematical
psychology artificial intelligence and
control theory IT addresses how systems
of any sort be they artificial or
natural can learn to gain rewards and
avoid punishments in what might be very
complicated environments involving
states such as locations in a maze and
transitions between Estates so they
describe how an agent should behave
under some explicit notion of what that
agent is trying to optimize and in that
sense they offer a normative framework
to understand Behavior so we kind of can
understand if an agent or a patient or a
participant would act in the most
optimal way how would this participant
act and if they deviate from that we can
perhaps understand a little bit more the
causal in terms of how they deviate or
why they deviate another model that's
quite popular the beta model so the
patient model is a prominent idea in
modern computational neuroscience and
that is that the brain maintains and
updates internal probabilistic models of
the world that serve to interpret the
environment and guide our actions in
doing so it uses calculations akin to
the well-known statistical models of
Bayesian inference so when applied to
Psychiatry this approach a
conceptualizes mental illness as the
brain trying to interpret the world
through a distorted internal
probabilistic models or incorrectly
combining such internal models with
sensory information generating
maladaptive beliefs So within Bayesian
Theory you kind of have your priors and
your likelihood and there is this idea
that there is a wrong or a misalignment
in how you update these to make a
prediction about your environment for
certain mental disorder and the last one
is a neural network model so for example
there's a paper from nature that is deep
neural network models in Psychiatry and
right now deep neural network models are
used to for example train on neural
Imaging data then you can make these
conclusions non-linearity and also
pooling you can combine everything into
one deep neural network architecture and
then for example make a prediction if
someone would be a patient or if someone
would be healthy according to their
brain physiology so these are some
examples of the type of models that are
being used so if you want to learn a
little bit more about how to use these
models I would for example follow kind
of the same pipeline as I explained in
my how to learn computational
Neuroscience from scratch and that's
just to First Learn Python then do
machine learning course for example on
Coursera and afterwards find a project
to apply this to so the second thing I
want to talk a little bit about is the
types of data you can use in these kind
of models so there are different types
of data that you could use so one thing
that's really hot and coming is to use
mobile phone data so you can really
track every day how a participant moves
through space Also their typing speed
for example or what kind of websites
they go to another big data set is
neuroimaging data genetics behavior and
lastly also for example your circadian
rhythms or your sleep and wakefulness
Cycles could be indicative of certain
psychiatric disorders being present
so then at chapter four I kind of want
to talk about the tools you could use to
learn about it so as I said before a
computational Psychiatry is a really new
field so there have been some books
written about it over the last few years
but I would mainly look at papers so I
want to give you a list of a few papers
that I would recommend you start reading
if you've never heard about
computational Psychiatry before so I
made a list of five computational
Psychiatry papers that you could start
reading so they go over different models
that I explained before so reinforcement
models patient learning and also deep
neural network models and I think if you
read these papers you will have a really
good understanding of where the field is
currently at and which gaps are still
present so the first one is
computational Psychiatry and the second
one is from reinforcement learning
models to Psychiatry and neurological
disorders the third one is computational
Psychiatry as a bridge from Neuroscience
to clinical applications the fourth one
is beyond lumping and splitting a review
of computational approaches for
stratifying Psychiatry disorders and I
find this one really interesting because
it really pertains to individual
predictions for patients and
participants and the fifth one is
realizing the potential of mobile mental
health new methods for new data in
Psychiatry so this last one is really
about how to use mobile phone data to
make a mobile phone footprints for
individual participants which I find a
really interesting method of course so
some books that I would recommend so
I've used for this video computational
Psychiatry a primer it's written by a
lot of researchers that are currently
working on the field so it's a
combination of some papers that have
been written on the field so I think
that's also a really good tool something
else that I would definitely recommend
if you're gonna start in computational
Psychiatry is also to learn a little bit
about the history and the use of
language in Psychiatry because the
diagnosis of mental disorders is still
to this day quite controversial virtual
and it definitely changes throughout the
years what kind of behavioral patterns
are considered as psychiatric disorders
and what's considered a normal within
the population and I think you need to
be quite sensitive of your language if
you want to work in this field so even I
probably in five years this video will
be quite outdated of what we think
mental disorders are so the difference
between the right word and the almost
right word is the difference between
lightning and the lightning bug and
that's by Mark Twain so if you're
interested in the language and also
society and mental disorders I would
definitely recommend reading Michael
Foucault so Madness and civilization so
Michael Focus thoughts or mental health
are quite complex and nuanced but he
argued in general that the concept of
mental illness is mostly a social
contract that is used to control and
discipline individuals so quite
controversial and also a book that I
would recommend uh is this one the
Divide itself also quite controversial
but the defined itself is an existential
study and Sanity and Madness and it's a
book by the British psychiatrist and
author Lang so the book explores the
idea that mental illness is not purely a
medical condition but rather a reaction
to the stresses and conflicts of living
in a society that is at odds with one's
sense of self so I think this is still
really a hotly debated topic how much
mental health is your environment how
much it's genetics how much its brain
patterns or how much is actually just
Society condemning certain individuals
to behave a certain way so I definitely
think this is an interesting debate that
you should follow a little bit if you're
interested in computational Psychiatry a
course that I would definitely follow if
you're interested in computational
Psychiatry is the computational
Psychiatry course in Zurich it's amazing
all their videos are online every year
they hold it in the Summers so if you're
a master student or a PhD student in the
field of Neuroscience you can definitely
apply and attend it live but also all
the lectures are recorded So if you
don't have the resources or the ability
to travel to Switzerland you can also
watch everything online and I think
they've done it for a couple of years so
there's definitely enough material to
Deep dive into so the final question if
you made it to the end of this video
which I would be really curious about is
do you think throwing equations at
mental illnesses could be useful or do
you think this is a field that should
not exist I would love to actually hear
some different opinions on this field
because I do think some of the things
that are being done are a little bit
controversial and with that I also want
to leave you with a final quote from
Foucault's book on Madness and
civilization and that is on the
conversation with mental disorders in
the Serene world of mental illness
modern man no longer communicates with
the madman on one hand the man of
realism delegates The Physician to
Madness thereby authorizing a relation
only through the abstract universality
of disease on the other the man of
Madness communicates with Society only
by the intermediary of an equally
abstract reason which is order physical
and moral constraint the anonymous
pressure of the group the requirements
of Conformity so this was a little
introduction in computational Psychiatry
I hope you found it interesting and see
you next week bye